images tragiques un ciel noyés par dp
panache de fumée le grondement permanent
des bombes
mario paul où les flammes dévorent les
immeubles un art
et des habitants qui ont à peine le
temps de sortir qu'il faut de nouveau se
mettre à l'abri
c'est une télévision de moscou qui filme
elle est entrée dans la ville en même
temps que les chars russes qui ont
réussi une percée
trois cent cinquante mille personnes
toujours piégés dans la ville assiégée
depuis près de trois semaines
ça c'était chez moi avec le beau jardin
devant
voyez ce qu'il en reste
c'est une petite apocalypse
ces derniers jours des couloirs
humanitaires ont permis l'évacuation
d'environ 30000 personnes
dont ses enfants grièvement blessés
macha 15 ans a dû être amputé de la
jambe droite
cette jeune fille qui a perdu sa jambe
est tellement traumatisée qu'elle a été
incapable de manger ou de boire pendant
plusieurs jours
on était obligé de la nourrir par
intraveineuse
dans le couloir de l'hôpital un père de
famille pleure effondré y'a pas de
behrami j'ai couru vers ma fille je
voulais dominique a à dominique a
mais elle était allongée inconsciente
ma fille chérie news je n'ai pas réussi
à te protéger
aucun bilan précis du nombre de victimes
n'a pu être établi pour marioupol mais
les morts se compteraient par milliers